SHAWN SIMISTER: Thank
you, everyone,
for coming out today.
It's a great turnout, so I
really appreciate that on the
last day of I/O here.
Today I'm going to be talking
about knowledge-based
application design patterns.
My name is Shawn Simister.
I work in developer relations
here at Google.
I work with the knowledge group,
which, as you might
know, includes search.
But it also covers a lot of
other developer products like
Freebase, Google Refine,
Schema.org, and now, the
Knowledge Graph.
I've been building web apps for
over 10 years now, working
in developer relations
for a year.
I've been a member of Freebase
community since it started
five years ago.
And this presentation is sort of
collections of lessons that
I've learned from building
applications on top of a
Knowledge Graph, and also from
helping developers like
yourselves build applications
on top of a Knowledge Graph.
So what does it mean to be a
knowledge-based application?
The web is changing.
The web is changing from being
a web documents to becoming a
web of things.
The users expect applications
that know
about real world things.
Real world things that they care
about and not just pages
and links that they can
do things with.
This creates opportunities
to build new types of
applications and enhance
existing applications.
So today I'm going to show you
some examples of applications
built on top of a
Knowledge Graph.
I'm going to show you some
design patterns help you tap
into the power of the
Knowledge Graph.
And we're going to
look at some code
samples to get started.
So most of you have probably
seen this now.
This is the Knowledge Graph,
Google's Knowledge Graph,
showing up in search.
We've launched this
this month.
And if you search for a thing in
Google, most likely you'll
see one of these cards here
that gives you some
information about that entity
Google's Knowledge Graph has
over 500 million entities, 3.5
billion facts about those
entities, and it's being
integrated into more and
more parts of Google.
So on Wednesday's keynote, I'm
sure you saw the Knowledge
Graph showing up in
Android as well.
So what is a Knowledge Graph?
A Knowledge Graph is a
collection of entities--
well, first and foremost,
it's a graph.
And, as you can see here, this
is the graph representation of
that knowledge panel
that we just saw.
And so each one of these little
circles, or nodes in
the graph, are the real world
things, the entities that
we're talking about.
And then the lines to connect
them together are the edges,
those 3.5 billion facts.
And these are actual meaningful
relationships
between entities.
We're not just saying that
they're related in some way,
we're saying exactly how
they're related.
So you can see, here,
all the information
that we had in search.
This is how it looks
in the graph.
Some of the topics are entities,
or some of the nodes
are entities.
Some of the nodes are actually
mediator nodes.
So you can see, like a film
performance, it shows what
character he played
in that film.
Or for his spouse, it'll show
what time period and that
person was married to him.
And so all this data gets pulled
together and displayed
in search or other
applications.
And this is really useful.
This can be really useful for
your applications as well.
Because Knowledge Graph is
very high quality data.
It's deduplicated, so
there's no ambiguity
between different entities.
We know that this is the Chuck
Norris the acts in Walker
Texas Ranger, not some other
Chuck Norris just because the
name matches.
And most importantly,
it's searchable.
So we've come up with some
really interesting ways of
letting you use this data
in your application.
Now I'm going to talk
a little bit about
Freebase's Knowledge Graph.
So Freebase started off as a
local startup called Metaweb.
Metaweb was acquired by Google
in 2010 and that team went on
to help build the Knowledge
Graph here at Google.
Freebase lives on as the open,
public facing part of the
Knowledge Graph.
It's crowd-sourced,
so anyone can
contribute, like Wikipedia.
There's 2.3 million topics, and
those are organized into
over 2000 different types of
things, people, places,
locations, events, all
that sort of stuff.
We have RESTful APIs that let
you tap into that, and I'll
show that a little bit later
in the presentation.
Everything is licensed under a
Creative Commons attribution
license, so it's very easy to
take it out, use it, use it
commercially, as long
as you give
attribution back to Freebase.
There's complete data dumps,
so at any point you can
download everything, all those
23 million topics, and do
whatever you want with them.
And most importantly, it's one
of the major sources for
Google's Knowledge Graph.
So a lot of that high quality
data from Freebase winds up
being in the Knowledge
Graph and in
those products at Google.
So this is what freebase
looks like.
Every one of those 23 million
entities and Freebase has its
own page as well as a schema.
All the types, those 2000
commons types, have their own
page, like this.
And every property even
has its own page.
And anyone with a Google
account can login.
Anyone with a Gmail account
can log in and contribute
data, create new schema, add
topics, fix errors, much like
you would with something
like Wikipedia.
So let's imagine what sort of
applications you can build
with this type of
Knowledge Graph.
You could build applications
that understand real world
entities, the real people,
places, and things that the
users care about.
You can build applications that
allow users to interact
with these entities
in new ways that
they couldn't before.
You can build applications the
scale to millions of topics,
rather than just a small list
of hand curated topics.
So next, we're going to look
at some ways you can build
these sorts of applications
right now.
We're going to look at some
discovery patterns, which are
ways to convert strings
into things.
We'll go into that shortly.
We'll look at interaction
patterns, which are ways of
navigating through the Knowledge
Graph to find
interesting pieces of data.
And finally, we'll look at
presentation patterns, which
is ways to display that
data to the user
in informative ways.
Put it in context with
your content.
So discovery patterns.
Discovery patterns cover,
as I said, turning
strings into things.
Taking the user input and
figuring out which entities
they're talking about.
And so this is usually the
first step in your
application.
This is usually how you start,
how you go from user input to
a Knowledge Graph.
But it's not just limited
to strings, either.
As we've seen, you can
have voice input.
You can give it a URL.
We'll see some examples of
taking documents and getting
entities out of them.
So the first pattern we'll
look at is the
reconciliation pattern.
And the problem that this
addresses is, when a user has
an entity in mind, they have
some key words, they want to
describe it to you, but they
don't know what the identifier
of that entity is
in your graph.
How to look it up in your
Knowledge Graph
of 500 million entities.
Keywords can be ambiguous.
If they type in "John Smith,"
what do you give them back.
And there are some problems,
too, of, even when you show
them the entity, how do you know
that this is the one that
they're looking for.
So there's a couple solutions
that we've come up with.
The first is the easiest one,
which is just to come up with
a list of matching entities.
Show them all the John
Smith's and let them
pick from that list.
That doesn't always scale, you
need some way to rank the
matches as well.
But we'll show you
how that works.
The other way is to use
reconciliation algorithms to
do it automatically.
So we have a number of
techniques that we use
internally, and we're working
on ways to open that up to
developers.
But basically, you look at the
different properties and you
say, do these people have the
same dirth date, does this
company have the same location
for their headquarters, and
you match them that way.
And then, what we've found is
the best technique is to
combine both of those.
So, use the algorithm to match
80% of them, and then use
humans to match the last 20%,
the really hard ones that the
algorithms can't match.
So let's look at an
example of that.
Ranker.com is a site that lets
you create and share ranked
lists of things.
And so they use Freebase data as
a source for those things.
And here we see their list
editor where I'm creating a
new list of the best movie
villains of all time, and I
want to add Goldfinger.
So here they're using the
reconciliation pattern to let
me type in some text, give me
some suggestions of entities
that match in their site, and
then let me select those.
And you can see here that
it also gives the--
it's a little bit small
at the bottom--
But it also gives us the option
to create a new entity
if it doesn't exist.
So that lets them grow their
Knowledge Graph as well.
This is Freebase Suggest.
This is an open-source jQuery
plug-in that we created.
And let me just show you why we
created this to help you do
reconciliation in your apps.
So say I'm looking for
a film director.
I'm looking for Francis
Ford Coppola.
I'm going to start typing
in "Francis" "Ford"--
All right, so now you
see, it's come up
with a couple matches.
And I can hover over those and
see a short description of
what that entity is like.
You can see it's giving me
some clues, like a photo.
That's a pretty strong clue.
Date of birth, again,
another strong clue.
So I'll click on this one.
And you can see here, this
is the code that I used.
Very simple, one line of
JavaScript jQuery.
And this is the data
that I get back.
So I'm getting back to name, but
I'm also getting back the
unique ID in the Freebase
Knowledge
Graph for that entity.
And then I can use that
application to do a whole
bunch of things, which we'll
see in a second.
This also has an API,
so RESTful API,
where you call this.
So you can just pass text
and get back those
suggestions as JSON data.
So it's very easy to add this
reconciliation to your
application, and to do that
sort of entity-based
recommendation.
So when would you use this?
Like I said, when we
need entity IDs for
known entity names.
So when the user has an entity
in mind, but they don't know
which ID it corresponds to in
our database or our graph.
When we need to disambiguate,
when we don't know which John
Smith they're talking about.
And when we can use tags to
organize our content.
When we have too much content
that tagging would lead to too
many ambiguities, then we can
actually annotate content with
entities instead.
Now let's see one more
example of that
reconciliation pattern.
This is a social app called
Amen, and it lets you state
strong opinions about
real world things.
And they actually use Freebase
data to let people select an
entity, and then state a strong
opinion about it, and
then share that with
their friends.
And one of the interesting
things about that is that,
once you share that, they
actually know about the
entities that you're sharing
your opinion about.
So you can click on an entity.
Say it says, Blue Bottle Coffee
is the best place for
coffee in San Francisco.
You can click on that Blue
Bottle Coffee and see all the
other opinions that people have
had about that entity.
So it opens up some new
possibilities for how you want
to interact with the data.
The second discovery pattern
we're going to look at is
called the detection pattern.
And this is where the user wants
to learn more about some
subject matter, but it's
not just a string.
It's maybe an article, or
an image, or a video.
Something that they couldn't
just easily just type into a
text box, like we saw.
So there are a number of
solutions for this.
The most common one is called
named entity recognition.
So this is a family of
logarithms to people use to
automatically detect name
densities, these things, from
an article.
Another way to do is to
use structured markup.
So there's a lot more web pages
these days using things
like schema.org, RDFA,
micro formats.
And you can actually use that to
pull the things out of the
page, and then use the
reconciliation pattern that we
just saw to figure out which
entities they correspond to in
the Knowledge Graph.
This is DBPedia Spotlight.
This is an open-source project
built on top of DBPedia.
DBPedia is a project that's goal
is to extract structured
data from Wikipedia.
So it's a lot like Freebase in
that sense, except for it's
limited to just Wikipedia, and
they produce RDF data.
And they've created this
incredible tool to do
named-entity recognition
using DBPedia data.
The great thing is that, because
Freebase and DBPedia
are both using Wikipedia data,
all of our IDs link together
quite easily.
So you can actually use DBPedia
to get the IDs out,
and then convert those into
Freebase IDs quite easily and
use that data in your
application.
So when do you use this?
You use this when you have a lot
of content, thousands of
articles, or more content then
you could annotate by hand.
When you need to identify
relevant
entities with your content.
So say you have a lot of user
generated content, and you
want to be able to navigate that
in ways, like we saw with
Amen, that are related to the
entities being discussed.
You can use this.
And like I said, when
we just have too
much content to markup.
A number of other services,
OpenCalais, AlchemyAPI,
Zemanta, they all use Freebase
identifiers to look up
entities in text.
So a lot of great API that you
can use to mash up that data
with other sources.
So that was discovery
patterns.
That's how you go from raw
content, or user input, to IDs
in your Knowledge Graph.
Now we're going to look at
interaction patterns, which
is, once you have those entity
IDs, what sort of interesting
things can you do with them.
How can you use that
to find interesting
paths through the graph.
So the first pattern that we're
going to look at is
called the faceting pattern.
And the problem is that the
first step might overturn a
lot of results.
You might have said, I want to
find computer programmers.
And it returns thousands
of results.
Now what do you do?
A lot of times, the data
that the user is
looking for is large.
It's not all that it's
that interesting.
You want to find a way to filter
it down, but there's no
specific way that you
can filter it down.
If you're dealing with an entity
of 500 million topics,
thousands of different types of
topics, there's no single
way to organize that.
So facets are a very flexible
way to let the user drill down
into that data.
Basically how it works is, you
look at all the different
properties of the data, and you
count up how frequently
each one occurs, and you
let the user choose.
So you can see here, this image
I have is from Google
Refine, which is a product that
we've open sourced for
working with messy data.
And it's taken some zip codes,
counted them up, and we let
the user click on those to see
just the data that concerns
that zip code, or, political
party, here.
And so the idea is, you give the
user a broad overview of
what sort of data they're
looking at, let
them click on it.
Filter down those results until
they find a smaller set
of entities that they're
really interested in.
One of the areas where we've
done this is actually in
Google search.
If you do a Google search
for something that
looks like an entity--
or something that looks
like a recipe--
We actually do faceted
search on the side.
So here, I've done a search for
"margarita recipe." And
you can see that we faceted
popular ingredients, the
cooking time, the number of
calories in the recipe.
I don't know why you'd
be concerned with
calories for a margarita.
And so if you click on any one
of those facets, you can
actually filter that down.
It automatically does a
constrained Google search, and
really lets you dig into that
data quite quickly.
So this is an example of the
"miquel," MQL, query language
that Freebase uses to
search entities.
At the top here, we have
a query for our API.
And at the bottom
is the result.
You can see it's just a
simple JSON structure.
It's query by example.
So here we're asking for the ID
and the name of things in
our graph which have the
profession "software
developer" and the type
"people person."
And you can see, the bottom half
with the results, it's
filled in some of those
null values.
We have ESR, Sergey Brin.
But if you actually run that
on the Freebase API, you'll
get over 100 results of
famous programmers.
So this sort of query could
easily be used to generate
those facets, using Freebase
data, in your application.
Here we can see using
the Google API
client library in Python.
It's very simple to take that
same query that we had on the
previous slide here, the top,
and pass that in to the
Freebase API service, and get
that data back in Python.
It's not just Python, there's
libraries for Java,
JavaScript, PHP, Ruby.
It's quite a few, and
we're creating more.
So when would you use this?
Again, when you have too many
facts about an entity, you're
not sure which ones users are
interested in, you need to
filter down a little bit more.
Or also when you have sparse
or undifferentiated data.
So maybe you have 2 million
topics called "John Smith,"
and 80% of them don't really
have any interesting data
associated with them.
And you're looking for the most
notable, famous ones.
You can use faceting to narrow
it down that way.
And mostly, just when you have
so many results that you can't
provide pages and pages
of results that
people can go through.
So as I was talking
about earlier,
this is Google Refine.
This is a tool that we built
to clean up messy data.
And it relies extensively on
faceting to let users drill
down into large data
sets, hundreds of
thousands of rows of data.
And so they can create custom
facets on the left hand side
there, to drill down
into this data.
And we actually created this
tool as a way to load entities
into the Freebase
Knowledge Graph.
The next pattern we're going
to look at is the
recommendation pattern.
So this is when you have a large
Knowledge Graph, and you
want to encourage people
to explore through it.
If you have 500 million
entities, how are you going to
get people to visit all those
entities when they might just
look for the most
popular ones.
So the great thing is, because
everything in our graph is a
node connected with edges, we
know how they're related, and
we know how closely
they're related.
So we can actually come
up with meaningful
recommendations for what other
entities you might be
interested in, or what other
content you might be
interested in based
on the entities
that are being discussed.
And not only can we say that
they're related, but we can
even tell you how
they're related.
So that makes really strong
recommendations for why you
should check out that
other content.
We can go back to the example
with the Knowledge Graph here,
which is what we've done.
So we say, all right you're
interested in Chuck Norris.
You might also be interested
in some of the movies or TV
shows that he's done.
So we can recommend some of the
most notable ones here.
And we can actually tell you
that we know they're movies
and TV shows with
Chuck Norris.
It's a stronger recommendation
than the one before, which is
just things that you've
also searched for.
So when would you use this?
Like I said, when there are
too many possible ways to
organize the content.
You can't just come up with
a single hierarchy for
browsing the data.
Especially when you have things,
like music or movies,
which users have are really
personalized preference for.
You're going to want to use
recommendation in that case.
Because there's no single way
to give users the best movie
for every user without
using recommendation.
This is one more example.
This is a service
called ookaboo.
It's a repository of freely
licensed images
organized by entity.
So the data all comes
from Freebase and
the Wikimedia Commons.
Every entity in ookaboo
has its own page.
So here, you can see this page
for F-22 Raptor pictures.
There's pictures about that
entity, and then over on the
right hand side, there's related
entities as well.
So you can see it's not just
keyword matches, it's actually
related to the same domain.
So either US Air Force
or F-16, F-35,
that sort of thing.
So ookaboo uses Freebase data
to figure out which entities
might be related.
And that makes it easier to
explore this large corpus of
images in interesting ways.
So those were the interaction
patterns.
That's how you can kind of dig
through a large amount of
content using entities.
Now we're going to look at
presentation patterns, which
is kind of the last stage
of your application.
This is how you take this entity
data, present it to the
user, show them that you know
which things they're talking
about, which things they care
about, and let them do
interesting things with that.
It's not just a shiny,
distraction visualization.
All this data coming from the
graph is real, factual data.
So when you're putting that on
the screen, that's really
helping the user out and
showing them something
interesting about
these topics.
This is really the key to using
a Knowledge Graph with
existing content or user
generated content by being
able to mash it up with the data
from the Knowledge Graph.
So let's see some examples
of how that works.
So the first pattern is
the simplest one.
This is a summarization
pattern.
And this is just when we want
to describe an entity.
So the user has done a search
for something, or the user has
selected something from
Freebase suggest.
And we want to give them that
confirmation that we know
which entity they're
talking about.
And we need to come up with a
short, concise description of
what it is.
So the solution is to show
things like image description,
disambiguating properties like
date of birth, what year a
movie came out in.
Sometimes there's multiple
movies with the same name, but
came in different years,
remakes, that sort of thing.
So let's see an example
of how that works.
So you'll recognize
this is Freebase
Suggest, like we had before.
But we're actually going to use
brand new Freebase topic
API, which we're launching today
to get a nice, little
summary of that topic.
So let's look for "Chuck
Norris." You can see it's
suggesting entities here.
And this is all live, this is
going off of the Freebase
Knowledge Graph right now.
So you can try this yourself.
So we'll select first
result there.
Looks like the right one.
You can see it's provided a
little summary here for us.
But we actually used the topic
API with some jQuery.
I didn't show the whole code
snippet here, but you can do
view source on the slides to see
how you build this little
topic summary to confirm with
the user that this is actually
the entity that they're
talking about.
So when would we use this?
When we have content that needs
to be put in context.
So we'll see an example
of that in a second.
But, basically, when you want
to say, this article or this
video talks about the
specific content.
Not just a tag like "John
Smith," but an actual entity
that you can click on and find
out more information about.
And also, when we want to
encourage users to navigate
the site in a way which
relates to entities.
So we've seen this with search,
when we start showing
the knowledge cards.
People started clicking a lot
on all those blue links,
navigating search in new ways
based on things in the
relationships between things,
rather than just
searching by keyword.
So this is an example from
the Wall Street Journal.
And they're using Freebase
data to add that sort of
navigation structure
to their content.
So this is an article that
does their weekly movie
reviews, and there's four
different movies, all being
reviewed in this article.
But you can see on the right
hand side here, they have a
little summary of each entity.
That data's all coming
from Freebase.
And that gives you a quick
snapshot of which entities are
being talked about
in this article.
But it also lets you click
through to find out more
information about the director
or related reviews.
So this is a great way that they
can encourage their users
to navigate their content based
on the entities that are
being discussed.
I should also mention that none
of this would be possible
if they hadn't reconciled
their entities.
So that first reconciliation
pattern that we saw in the
discovery patterns at
the beginning--
They're only able to display
these recommendations and
these entities because they've
matched all the things in
their knowledge base to the
things in Freebase.
It's also a great example of a
mashup pattern, which is what
we're going to see next.
Where they're combining their
content with content from the
Knowledge Graph.
So the mashup pattern.
The mashup pattern is when a
user wants to see different
types of information about
this same entity.
So it could be that they want to
know, videos from YouTube,
text from Wikipedia, facts
from Freebase.
They want to mash that all up
in one location and see
everything there is to know
about this entity.
Or it could all be from the same
source, but it could be
different perspectives
on the same entity.
So some entities, some people,
are also politicians, are also
authors, have also appeared
in films.
And you might want to break that
down by different genres,
different perspectives
on the same entity.
The problem is, it's hard to
combine this data from all
these different sources if
you're not using strong
identifiers.
If you just do a keyword search
on YouTube for your
John Smith entity, you're not
going to get back high
quality, relevant data that
you could mash up with
whatever you found with the
keyword search for John Smith
on Wikipedia.
But if you have strong
identifiers, ways to link that
together, you can create
really good mashups.
So the solution is to create
those links, either through
manual reconciliation or those
automatic reconciliation
algorithms we saw.
Or, to use existing links in
a source like Freebase.
And this encourages users to
jump between the different
contexts for that same entity.
When they know that they can
rely on it being the exact
same topic, they're more
likely to click around.
So let's see an example here.
This is seevl, which is a Chrome
extension that works
with YouTube.
And so what seevl's done is,
when you go to YouTube, when
you're looking at say, a music
video, they'll reconcile that
to the artist in Freebasee,
figure out which artist you're
talking about, and then display
some recommendations
here on the side.
Additional videos, facts about
it, and links to more
information about that artist.
They're able to make really
strong recommendations using
the recommendation pattern,
because they have that
information in the Freebase
graph about how this artist
relates to other artists.
So this is an example, using
that topic API that I showed
you earlier, of how to just go
into Freebase and get all
these identifiers So right here,
we're looking up San
Francisco, and we're saying,
give me all the foreign keys,
all these identifiers on other
sites that you know about for
San Francisco.
And so we have a number of
different key sources.
It's going to return
the Wikipedia URL.
t's going to return a number of
different sources that all
talk about that San Francisco
entity, and not just things
that match the San Francisco
keyword.
So when would you use this?
When you need to see information
from different
perspectives, and when you
need to mashup data from
different sources.
So when you can't get all the
information from one source,
you need to combine it
on your website.
You need to be able to have
these identifiers to look it
up on other websites.
A great resource for this is
a site called sameas.org.
Sameas.org is a data hub that
links together all these
different data sets
on the web.
It's completely open, so anyone
who owns a data set can
contribute their links
to this data set.
So Freebase has contributed
all their entity IDs to
sameas.org.
There's a simple JSON API.
So you can see here, I've looked
up the Freebase RDF URL
for the San Francisco topic
we were just looking at.
And its returned a list of all
the equivalent identifiers on
the web for that entity.
So the identifiers at New York
Times, you can see ookaboo's
in there, GeoNames, Wikipedia.
There's quite a few data
sets, and they're
always adding more.
So this is a great example of
how you can easily combine
data from different sources
once you have those entity
identifiers.
Last pattern we're going
to look at is the
visualization pattern.
And this is when you have many
different entities that you
want to display.
More than just the four entities
that you saw in that
Wall Street Journal article.
What if you have 40, how
do you display those?
And also, the different entities
on the Wall Street
Journal article were only
related because they came out
in the same week.
But what if there's more
meaningful relationships
between the entities?
How do you show the
relationships as well as the
facts and the image related
to those entities?
So there are number of different
solutions to this,
but basically, you can use data
visualization techniques
to display a lot of entities at
the same time, while also
keeping some of the semantics
about how they're related.
So for example, if you have
families or organizations with
people in it, you can visualize
that as a tree.
If you have places or
events, you can
visualize that on a map.
Events can also be vizualized
on a timeline, as
we'll see in a second.
One of the easiest ways
is, you can just
visualize it as a graph.
So that slide I showed you at
the beginning, where Chuck
Norris is a node connected to
other nodes with edges, that's
one way of visualizing it.
And also, bubble charts are a
really interesting way to
visualize a lot of information
about entities when there's no
easier way to do it, like
maps or timelines.
So this is Thinkbase.
This is an interface
that someone
built on top of Freebase.
I'd encourage you to check
it out afterwards.
There's a link there
at the bottom.
It's an interactive interface
to Freebase.
So here I've looked up
Prometheus, the movie, and
it's expanded a number of the
relationships for me.
And I can see the different
related
entities, how they're related.
I can click on those to explore
what other entities
are related to those.
So it's a really interesting
way to explore the data.
If you get to some really dense
topics, like United
States, that have a lot of
entities connected to them, it
can get a little
bit confusing.
But in most cases, it's pretty
cool way to navigate.
So we use visualization patterns
when it's important
to be able to see the
relationships between multiple
entities at the same time.
And like I said, when there's
far too many different
entities that we want to show to
be able to just list them,
like you saw in the Wall
Street Journal article.
The last example I want to show
you here is an amazing
site called conflict history.
Again, they're using Freebase
data to mashup a lot of
different entities about
different military conflicts
over the centuries.
And actually, you can see
here, they've got a map.
So they've plotted all these
different events on a map, but
they're also plotting them on
a timeline at the same time.
So let me see if I can just
open that up here.
This is actually a great example
of using a lot of
these different visualization
techniques
together in the same app.
So here we can see that that map
is pulling data out of the
Knowledge Graph, planting
it on the map.
We've also got this timeline.
So we can drag the window
at the bottom.
Or we can expand it, as well, to
see military conflicts that
happened in this time period and
in this part of the world.
We can hover over any of the
entities, and you can see it's
pointing to the item
in the list that
corresponds to this conflict.
And then, you can actually go
here and click on "more
information," and they're using
that mashup pattern to
pull in data from Wikipedia
using those identifiers in
Freebase to tell you more about
the Battle of Ty-ho Bay.
So to sum things up here, we
first looked at discovery
patterns, which was a way to
surface entities in your
application.
To take this the strings or
the input that the user is
giving you, and convert
that into things.
We then looked at interaction
patterns, which is a way to
navigate through a Knowledge
Graph to facet, or to make
recommendations based on what
you think the user might be
interested in.
And then we finished with
presentation patterns as a way
to create informative user
interfaces and surface those
entities in your content.
So I hope that this encourages
you to consider adding entity
data to your application,
consider building applications
on top of Freebase or other
Knowledge Graphs.
And I've put together a list of
links here to the APIs that
I mentioned, to some of the code
libraries, and also tools
like Google Refine and DBPedia
Spotlight, so you can dig in
and try out some of these
examples that
I've showed you today.
And this is not just for
creating new apps, this is
also a great way to extend
existing apps and create new
ways of exploring data that
you've already collected.
So thank you very much
for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]
I've put a copy of
the slides at
knowledgedesignpatterns.com, so
you can check out all the
examples, click through
to all the links.
This is my Google+ profile, so
feel free to follow me and ask
me questions.
I know, but if you go to
the URL, then you can
click on the link.
And you can also follow me on
Twitter, which is a little bit
shorter, I guess.
So I'm going to invite my
colleague Mike Masouras up
here on stage.
Michael works on Freebase
and the Knowledge
Graph here at Google.
And we'd have to take any of
your questions, or we'll be
hanging around here afterwards
if you have more questions.
We have microphones here and in
the aisles, if you would.
AUDIENCE: I am not all that
familiar with Freebase,
although it looks great.
I was just wondering, is there
the concept of a schema when
you have something of
a certain type?
Like you showed all these movies
on the Wall Street
Journal site.
Are they able to assume
there's going to be a
director, and producer, and
actors and actresses, and
stuff, or is there not really
that sort of structure to the
information?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So every entity in Freebase
can have one or more types
applied to it.
And the types are actually nodes
in the graph as well.
So you can go to Freebase, and
you can look up that people
person type, or the movie type,
or the director type,
and you can see which properties
are suggested for
that type of entity.
And so yeah, it's really cool
the way that the topics, and
the types, and the properties
are all modeled as
nodes in the graph.
And you can query any of
them using the APIs.
AUDIENCE: That sounds
very open-ended.
I was wondering, though, is it
that there's a structure,
something that is a movie is
going to have certain types
filled in, or else it's
just considered
an incomplete record.
And maybe you could filter that
out in your results and
say, only give me the ones
that have been properly--
is there a constraint,
sort of?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, so there
aren't any really hard
constraints on which properties
have to be there.
Because this data's coming from
a number of different
sources, we can never really
guarantee that every book we
find is going to have the
author, or every film we have
is going to have the
release date on it.
But that's the value of having
kind of a crowd source
knowledge base, like Freebase,
is that people can come along
afterwards and fill
in those facts.
So all the types have properties
associated with
them, but they're
not required.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hi.
I was wondering if there's any
kind of call back API.
So as this data changes,
is there any way to
subscribe to that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: There's no
specific API to do it, but one
of the things we have in our
MQL search API is, you can
query based on a time stamp.
So you can say, give me all the
things that have changed
since this time stamp.
So that's one way of doing it.
It won't ping you when it's
done, you have to kind
of pull that data.
But all the time stamps for
every fact, for every topic
when it was created, are
recorded in the graph.
And you can query that
through the APIs
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHAWN SIMISTER: You're
welcome.
AUDIENCE: This is a little bit
of a high level question.
I attended some or your
presentation at Freeweb and
the RDF thing.
With the emergence of all these
platforms, you always
see an implication that you must
use this data to display
and certainly increase the power
of your presentations.
But are there any projects that
are trying to use this to
do some sort of reasoning?
The most obvious thing would be
something like Siri where
we're actually trying to
actively answer a question or
help the user.
Is there anything like that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, the stuff
that you saw in the
keynote on Wednesday
was powered by
Google's Knowledge Graph.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you're doing it.
But these projects are internal,
so there's no
outside developers trying to
do that based on these new
data platforms.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: We don't
actually start this
relationship.
So if you want to do
inference, you
have to do it yourself.
But there's other projects
out there, like
CYC are more academic.
And they are trying to model,
actually, intelligence and
relationships in the real
world between things
AUDIENCE: OK.
Academic.
OK.
Thank you.
SHAWN SIMISTER: I know there's
actually a start up, True
Knowledge, that does question
answering based
on a Knowledge Graph.
And they use data from Freebase
to be able to do that
question answering.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that anyone can
contribute to Freebase.
So you have your app and
you start getting
information from Freebase.
Maybe you store in your database
some IDs of entities
that you're users
have been using.
What happens when Freebase gets
updated and an entity
gets deleted from Freebase.
But you already have an idea,
and then you do a query.
And the entity's not there, or
maybe the entity was merged
with another entity.
So what happens with the
updates on that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So there
are a number of
different parts to that.
The first is that, we recommend
that if you're
building an application, you
just store the Freebase ID in
your database and whatever other
data you're going to add
to that entity.
But if you cache some of the
Freebase data locally, then it
gets very complicated.
So it is preferable to just
store the ID and then pull it
live from Freebase.
But again, there is still the
issue of, what if it gets
deleted, what if it gets merged
or changed in some way.
Because a lot of entities do
split and merge over time.
And we actually store all those
relationships in the graph.
So if an entity gets merged with
another one, if you call
up at that previous identifier
through the API, you'll get
redirected to the new entity.
So, as much as we can, we handle
that in the graph.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: And to add to
that, the Freebase graph is
append only, which means the
entire history of the graph is
available to you in Query BOL.
So at any point, you can
actually find out what
happened to any entity,
or any piece of data.
AUDIENCE: That's cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: The edges between
nodes, are they just sort of
like there's only one kind
of relationship?
Or are there more than
just like is a--?
You mentioned the moderator
nodes, which I guess, can act
as that sort of function.
SHAWN SIMISTER: There are
thousands of different types
of properties, relationships.
Go back to the beginning,
here.
You can see here, I've labeled
the different edges.
AUDIENCE: The coloring
is hard to see there.
Earlier--
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah,
if you go to
knowledgedesignpatterns.com,
you can zoom in on that a
little bit more.
But we have thousands of
different types of
edges in the graph.
There's all schema
for each of them.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
if any of those more
academically-oriented projects
are using this for seeding
formal ontology construction,
or anything like that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Off the
top of my head--
MICHAEL MASOURAS: I
think CYC and--
SHAWN SIMISTER: We have
a Freebase group on
mendeley.com, and there's a
collection of, like, over 100
papers now of people who are
using Freebase data in an
academic setting.
So I know there's a lot of
natural language programming
stuff, and some people that have
done things around schema
and ontology.
But I can't think of anything
off the top of my head.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
How often is the data in
Freebase being updated?
Like, are you guys pulling
in data constantly?
Like, if I go update a Wikipedia
page, how long does
it take before that
information makes
its way into Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Right,
so there's a lot
of different sources.
Obviously, the user
contributions are real time.
So some of those parts of my
presentation were live and
someone might have changed that
data as I was speaking.
Luckily, that didn't happen.
But the Wikipedia data, I
believe, comes in weekly now.
So we have a process that
looks for new topics and
Wikipedia automatically extracts
them, cleans them up,
and imports them
into Freebase.
There's also a little bit of
a lag, in that, we'll only
important new topics if they've
been filled out a
certain amount to try
and prevent--
MICHAEL MASOURAS: To prevent
spam and abuse.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Spam
and stub pages.
AUDIENCE: Just a real quick
second question.
What are the API limits
around using Freebase?
MICHAEL MASOURAS: Well,
currently there, you can do
100,000 requests per
day for free.
But there's also a form
there where you can
request more quota.
And you can describe your
project and we're usually
pretty generous and you
can go from there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's really cool
to see how we can extract
recognizable terms
out of text.
But I'm curious as to what
projects are out there for
using these extraction patterns
on fuzzier data, for
example images and sounds,
to identify elements in a
Knowledge Graph and in those
types of inputs.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, that's
a good question.
I don't have any resources
off the top of my head.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: No I
don't know if any--
for media, none, neither.
I think that a good way to find
out is to find out which
projects are out there that
extract just text, or any
piece of information
out of media.
And then do a second pass where
you reconcile that text
with entities.
So it's not an extra step to
reconclie with Freebase.
Sorry, it's not a different
process to
reconcile with Freebase.
You just follow the process
you're already following to
extract information, but then
you just reconcile that
information with Freebase.
SHAWN SIMISTER: We've seen
that in some cases, with
people that had a large
collection of videos.
And so they would actually
extract the entities from the
comments, or the text around
the videos as a
way of doing that.
But yeah, I'm sorry, I don't
have some examples right now
of images or video
recognition.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Is there any kind of
moderation on the data that
goes into Freebase?
So can anyone just chuck stuff
in, and does someone check
that it's actually correct?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Absolutely.
So we have a number of ways
of checking data.
We have a Freebase experts
group, which is kind of like a
community moderation group,
which monitors edits coming
into Freebase.
Because, as Michael said,
everything is append only.
With time stamps and attribution
for which user
wrote something, it's very easy
for us to go in there and
roll back any malicious edits
or bad data that's been
contributed.
So we have a number of
dashboards where we'll look
for suspicious stuff
coming in.
And then there are further steps
that we do later on to
identify bad data, clean that
up, and that sort of thing.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: Indeed, and
there's also tools that help
you do loads where other members
of the community will
QA the quality of the load
that you're doing.
So that's also helpful
to prevent
bad data from entering.
But in terms of malicious
use, like spam or--
Not only intentionally
malicious, we also have spam
filters post-fact.
So once the data is written in,
we recognize that certain
patterns are not right.
And then we flag them, and
then we review them.
AUDIENCE: So if I had, say,
an application that did
informations about books or
something, then would you
encourage--
Would it be a good thing to
get my users to post stuff
back up there, as
well as comsume?
Is that something that you want
to encourage, or do you
want it to be more separate?
Someone puts stuff in
and it's separate.
Someone takes stuff out.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: You mean,
from your own site?
AUDIENCE: Yes, let's say I have
a web app or an Android
app or something like that.
SHAWN SIMISTER: We certainly
want to encourage as much
contribution as possible.
Everyone benefits when people
are cleaning up that data and
contributing more facts.
There's one tricky part, which
is that, when you have kind of
distributed communities, if
someone is cleaning up a fact
on your site in your community
of books, and someone else on
Freebase disagrees with that
edit, and they get into a
little bit of an edit
war, how does that
communication happen?
But in general, we want to
encourage as much contribution
from other communities and
apps using Freebase.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: They actually
had a platform where
people could write
small web apps.
And it's all customized to the
particular use case and
encourages other users
to contribute data.
So we have a quota for writing,
because we try to
prevent this sort of
writing bad data.
And so what really happens is
that you ask for an extended
quota, because the base quota
for writing doesn't really
give you much.
And at that point, we're in the
conversation where we see
how you present your site and
how you teach your users to
enter correct data, because it's
not very straightforward.
And if everything's OK, then
we increase the quota and
that's very beneficial
for Freebase.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Are there topics that
have been identified as
very controversial?
How you deal with controversy?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, so one
of the things that so we do
is, we don't really have
any notability
requirements like Wikipedia.
So Wikipedia's around 2 million
and change topics, and
Freebase is 23 million topics.
So part of that is
that we don't
have notability standards.
People have added detailed
collections of porn stars, and
various things in there.
And we're creating schema that
will mark the objectionable
content so that developers can
filter that out in their
application, or filter it
in as the need may be.
AUDIENCE: How about things that
are of very high academic
quality, but they're still
controversial in the academic
circles and so forth?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So actually,
motivated by some of the use
cases we have here at Google
for using data from the
Knowledge Graph, we're looking
at ways to come up with much
more detailed categorizations
of different types of
objectionable content.
And we already have some
expertise in that area from
image search and other
parts like YouTube.
AUDIENCE: Do you have plans to
include authoritative sources
of information, government
sources?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, so we've
been talking to the World Bank
about loading some statistical
data and actually indicating,
in the graph, which facts come
from the World Bank.
So that people know where
that number comes from.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: We have
already loaded some data from
the World Bank and we have
authorities coming up, yeah.
And we plan to support this
as an official use case.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any sort
of plans for creating forms to
go and save data and put
it into entities?
SHAWN SIMISTER: We've been
experimenting with that.
I mean, the topic pages here--
AUDIENCE: A series of templates
as well, maybe you
want to have templates to go
and pull together all these
entities and present them
in a certain way.
Semantic MediaWiki does
something similar like that,
but there's performance issues
for very large data sets.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, in
the early versions of
freebase.com, we experimented
with a number of different
ways, tables, and maps, and
timelines, like I was talking
about, for filtering down
entities and displaying them.
It got very complicated, and we
found that developers could
do a better job in their
application than we could in
freebase.com trying
to serve everyone.
So right now, we just kind of
target the API use case.
MICHAEL MASOURAS: Yeah, and I
mean, there's a variety of
tools that get you from
anything, one single fact for
a single entity, all the way
to uploading of data set of
100,000 entities
into Freebase.
And in that spectrum, we have
all sorts of actual apps that
can help you do what
you want to do.
In the new freebase.com, that's
coming up soon, there's
actually an application that
works a little bit like you
described, where you you make a
query with the data that you
want to see and the data
that you want to enter.
And it presents you with a grid
sort of view where you
can go in, and then edit,
a property for every
entity, let's say.
Or something like that.
So that tool exists, yes.
SHAWN SIMISTER: One more.
AUDIENCE: It seems like named
entity extraction is kind of
the key to being able
to use Freebase from
just freeform data.
Are you aware of any tools for
doing named entity extraction
from small form content, like
tweets or Google+ posts,
things like that.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Nothing that you
could use right now, that
I can think of.
I know it's a very active
area of research.
I've seen papers using
Freebase data to do
that sort of thing.
I also know of a startup that's
using our data to try
and do that.
But I don't think that they've
announced anything yet.
AUDIENCE: OK thanks
SHAWN SIMISTER: Thank you.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Alright, well
thank you all very much for
coming out.
I really appreciate that.